money isn't real
if you know what you have you don't have
much and once you reach a certain level
of money you don't even know what you
have and you certainly don't own what
you have
outside entities which you may have a
stake in own what you have people who
have a lot of money understand it's very
difficult for me to even say how much
money i have but i can have anything i
want anytime i want
hi i'm sean reynolds and i'm still on
the lookout i've had some good dates i'm
liking my views you know i'm saying it's
all good right now charm aren't ya and
i've had some bad dates how do you think
you've done on the date i don't really
give a [ __ ] i'm not gonna lie about it
where are all the decent men not in my
dms that's for sure you get me i feel
like i'm rolling with the man then
what's going on about your fives it
seems like a lot of men don't know how
to treat a lady i'll just manhandle
everything and this girl's putting a
chest and chest in the nut like geez
will i have better luck this season what
would you do if my ex was after you he
can have you let's find out this
is grilling
i'm randy tate the third i'm here
because uh i was invited is that a good
answer
yeah i was invited so i thought i'd come
along why not there's already love in
the universe i've already found love i
found love with reality my friend i'm
already in love i'm in love with waking
up every day you know there's people who
are trying to stop me breathing and
they've yet to succeed i'm already in
love love life's great i used to think
that it was the man
and i was actually accurate thinking
that it was the man who was selling
himself to the woman but once you reach
a certain
level of achievement as a as a man it's
the woman who's trying to sell herself
to you
i've handled a bunch of difficult
situations in my life i'm i'm not
intimidated let's leave it at that we'll
see how it goes i would say i'm pretty
confident yeah overall yeah i think uh
confidence is born from adversity right
everything that doesn't kill you makes
you stronger can cheyenne ask you
whatever she likes anything she likes
find the most difficult question on the
planet tell her to throw a question card
away write a new one i'm ready
better be good i better struggle which
is obviously impossible so she should at
least try to make me struggle i spent my
life fighting in the cage i'm not i'm
not scared of her i think relationships
are a beautiful thing i think that the
synergy between men and women are a
beautiful thing if they are
correctly collaborated i think that
that's what makes society function i
think that's what makes the world
function i think that men men and women
falling in love and having children and
having families are very very beautiful
things as long as it's done correctly as
long as a woman obeys like she's
supposed to
and
i think the world can be a beautiful
place as long as gender roles are not
misconstrued or misunderstood so if sean
doesn't understand that i'll correct her
quickly and we'll fix the world and we
can move on
very nice to meet you
hello hi
you're really nice thank you let's do
two kisses one
two very nice to meet you
andrew tate what's your name andrew nice
to meet you um cheyenne australia shawn
reynolds if you're doing something
cheyenne reynolds we're gonna do
official yeah okay nice to meet you
cheers
i think she's uh attractive woman she's
good-looking
friendly demeanor
um
i can tell she thinks she knows things
so i look forward to correcting her
but that's usually how life works
finally see a man that makes an effort
how are you i'm good thank you yeah okay
where are you from i'm american but i
lived in england for a long time i lived
in a very prestigious part of the uk i
don't know if you've ever heard of luton
very prestigious yeah yeah yeah number
one luton okay was not expecting that so
i wasn't looting for a while and now i
live in europe so i've just come in yeah
okay because your accent it's like
really different than it it's pretty
mixed up i'm like a street dog my dear
i've been here i've been there half
american half english half luton half
everything else a bit of a mix never mix
that's cool how did you get here today
i flew in and flew in this morning flew
in it's different it's like different
yeah yeah yeah jump on the jet who flew
in on a jet
who is this guy
what about you you have a mix no yeah my
family were caribbean and english so the
caribbean side is the crazy side
or the english side's the crazy side um
i'd say the caribbean's the fun side
yeah
so you're fun and crazy not crazy i mean
it's the beginning of the day you can't
lie do i look like i'd lie to you
yes
i'm not a liar actually you're not a
liar everything you tell me for the rest
of this episode is gonna be a complete
truth yeah promise me yeah say i promise
i promise i really promise you'll see
honest faults and opinions
all right all right we'll see yeah um so
what do you do let me think of a lie
give me a second no you can't learn
you have to tell the truth i don't just
tell the truth why this we already
agreed you're telling the truth there's
only one of us can tell the truth one of
us can lie that's not good stuff i'm a
shoe salesman i sell shoes socks shoe
accessories polish et cetera et cetera
yeah i sell shoes
i'm doing all right yeah surviving sold
two pairs of shoes yesterday life's good
okay that's good he's a liar
so tell me a bit about you andrew i'm
not comfortable opening up too much i
really yeah because you know you might
work for
john law and the government no
i have to be careful what i say oh so
it's not commitment issues it's not no
it's not commitment issues it's more
just like
legality issues oh okay i like to go to
church i'm a man of god play scrabble do
you have faith
okay this is good this is an interesting
conversation that we can have on on
camera which is which is i'd say my
personal journey with god is between me
and god so i'm not one of those people
that like it's like yes i go to church
or yes i do this
don't you think that's a bit like lazy
christianity no not really because for
me i believe in love and i believe in
faith and i don't think it's just one
religion that you need to follow you
know i've got friends that are muslim i
agree i've got friends that are
christian you know i've got friends that
are spiritual so i don't
put myself in one category i understand
and i respect that completely but don't
you think out of respect for god himself
whether you're in dubai and you go to
the mosque or you're in england you go
to the church you should get up early on
a sunday despite all the booze and get
up and take an hour out of your life and
just show some respect no because
everyone's journey is with god is
personal you can be a lazy spiritualist
a lazy christian you can be a lazy
kickboxer right i'm a kickboxer i don't
train okay bro
i understand you're lazy it's okay i'm
not lazy do you have time for god
absolutely that's good do you get up
early on a sunday completely that's good
every single sunday of course that's
amazing and i think that being religious
is a beautiful thing and i think that a
lot of people try and say they're
spiritual or they're religious in a way
copping out on the one hour a week it
just feels a bit lazy to me i think you
can always find an hour away yeah no you
definitely could so maybe god sent me
here to make you go to church maybe
maybe you're here to enlighten me maybe
that's why yeah yeah um what kind of man
are you what's the spectrum i need you
to quantify it for me who's at the
bottom and who's at the top for me i
just say top like a high value man what
would you say constitutes a high value
man a high value man is someone that is
successful
financially okay i'd say it's someone
that's got a lot of integrity and good
morals
that is very well respected is very sure
of himself but also he's a very
family orientated man that's from me a
higher value man okay it's fine i'm high
value baby he's very sure of himself
yeah so what's a high value above you
pretty much basically what you said i
think a high value man is a capable man
i think capability can be
judged in many different ways and
capability is something which varies
depending on the situation you need a
man who is capable of doing lots of
different things that he doesn't do very
often you need a man who's capable of
being violent when the time appears of
course you need a man is capable of
making money you need a man who can kill
somebody and hold a baby in the same day
you demand with a very broad spectrum of
qualities and assets and capabilities
and this is actually what the most
difficult thing about being a man is
most people when i say most people let
me change that most females don't
respect how difficult it is to become a
high value man because to become a high
value man you need to have so many
different qualities and so many
different capabilities is a very
difficult thing to do you need to be
funny and smart and charismatic and
interesting with stories and and strong
and and rich with a nice car and a nice
apartment whereas to be a high value
female you need to be hot
if you're nice it's a bonus but it's not
even that necessary that's it if you're
a pretty female
even if you're a piece of [ __ ] person
you're gonna get messages on instagram
yeah whereas if you're a good-looking
man who lives with this mother you ain't
getting any messages
not really
i i think so i think that if you're a
good-looking man that's all you have
going for you i don't think you're gonna
succeed very well in life i know there's
very very pretty girls who have nothing
else going for them that manage to do
very very well yeah do you play chess
i'm okay
but if you look at the chess board right
the queen gets to jump all over the
board and the king has to move one
square at a time and i think that's done
very purposefully if you go to monaco
and you see a yacht and you see a man on
that yacht he had to work his entire
life and network his entire life and get
up early and deal with stress and tax
problems and police problems and work
his ass off to buy that boat what did
the girl have to do the girl was on that
boat the 19 year old ukrainian
she had to get a message on instagram
boom
so the man moves one square at a time
and the queen just jumps on board this
is the point female beauty is extremely
valuable the thing is there's a
difference between a high value man and
a high value woman for me a high value
woman is what kind of mother is she what
kind of like compassion has she got you
know has she got integrity has she got
morals is she loyal like all these other
qualities but i feel like men base it on
like just an aesthetic level i agree
with you if i meet a female i would like
her to be all those things especially
loyal it's the most important thing for
a female to be are you loyal mr loyal
man of god we already talked about
church
but
but the point is that to initially
attract a mate females the most
important thing for them is their looks
whereas a man i think is his status and
status is a far more varied spectrum
than looks alone being good looking
alone does not make you a high-stakes
male to be a high-stakes male you need
to have a bunch of things initially if
you're just pretty you're gonna get
attention whereas a man you need to have
a bunch of things to just get attention
do you understand do you agree with my
point not always listen there's men that
are funny that aren't that attractive
that can get attention it's like an
energy thing i disagree i just agree i
disagree i know what you're saying they
can get attention but i don't think
anyone would look at a funny guy who
lives with his mom and call him a
high-value male whereas if you get a
really really beautiful girl even if she
has nothing else going for her she'd be
considered high value i wouldn't say
high value no yeah we can disagree
that's fine are you a good partner the
best the best what makes you the best
besides you
and the police
i don't often answer questions
okay he's definitely had a police
interview in the past i don't like to
answer open-ended questions because i
feel like they're a trap why because
when you speak a lot
it's how you end up getting trapped
right it doesn't matter if it's a police
interview or anything else the more you
talk the worse
so i want you to be very very specific
with your parameters within the
questioning because that allows me to
answer them in a way which makes me look
the best i don't know i feel like a very
confident man that was very sure of
himself would just answer do you think
so
if because i feel like it just being
calculated okay a very innocent man
would he just answer the police yeah
if he's innocent then you've never dealt
with the police my dear that's not how
it works no no of course not he's
innocent it doesn't mean anything
innocent and guilty in and of itself is
a false paradigm
you have to understand that the world we
live in there is no black and white
there is there's no such thing it's all
a sliding scale they want to find you
guilty they'll find you guilty i
guarantee you
sold something to a mate on ebay seven
years ago and didn't pay tax boom you're
going to jail i'm enjoying this
conversation and i understand every
point she's making and i'm being
deliberately abrasive however the truth
is about the masculine feminine dynamic
is that females like men who are
completely in charge and run their life
exactly how they want
and they comply and bend to the man's
wills and lifestyle to to come along to
a woman and say how do you want me to be
so that you like me is is a death
is a death sentence for the relationship
so
that's how it works what kind of man do
you want to be honored a man who lives
true to himself and a man who goes to
sleep easy at night and a man who knows
that he's living true to his biological
necessities and and instincts
and tries his best not to hurt anybody
and leaves a positive impact on the
world are your actions congruent with
your words yeah what else would they be
i don't know i don't know you so that's
why i don't get to know you yeah we're
here to know each other of course they
are yeah i'm a positive man i'm a
positively inspirational and motivating
person okay what do you do this
motivation i inspire people to tell the
truth i think okay and i think a lot of
men live in a world now today where they
have to lie do you think in fact i would
basically guarantee that 99 of men are
lying at least 80 percent of the time
really that's a bit bold i i think it's
true because i think that someone else
men are liars women are correct men are
liars women wear makeup because men fall
in love with what they see and men lie
because women fall in love with
what they hear
men are liars because men are in
constant competition with other men and
they have to find a way to be
competitive and the easiest way to be
competitive is to lie
if you can sit there and convince a
woman that you're rich because you
bought her a 100
or 100 pound meal that's what you're
gonna do it's a lot easier to becoming
rich and women believe it and as long as
women are stupid enough to believe it
men are dishonest enough to lie for me
personally i'm the type of woman that is
action sad and words i don't get like
phased by actions can be a lie
you think flowers can't be a lie
do you think flowers 25 pounds on a
phone call or some [ __ ] delivery
dude can't be a lie no but there's
something like good men that wouldn't
even enter the head that that's a lie so
i feel like everything you're doing is
just very calculated life is calculated
almost like it's really nice
yeah
life life at the upper echelons at the
highest echelons of life is absolutely
not really calculated every single man
at the top echelon of life is a
calculated man you don't get there by
accident okay so do you want to get to
the top i'm already at the top of
echelon of man and when you're at the
top echelon of man it's a very very
calculated process you don't get there
by accident nothing good in life happens
on accident when you say men don't lie
because you believe in actions i'm
saying a lot of actions are lies am i
high-valued women in your eyes you're
very good-looking so i would say uh yeah
absolutely you're beautiful you seem
like you're a good person you seem
intelligent you're not stupid so i'd say
you're a high-value woman but your
actions dictate that right the most
important actions a woman can undertake
is loyalty every man out here knows that
disloyalty is the most disgusting thing
a female could ever do to her man but
are you loyal
let's not pretend that male loyalty and
female loyalty are the same thing but
loyalty is loyalty no but they're not
the same thing are they why is it not
because men and women are not the same
we are not the same you are correct then
okay so we agree no but i'm not agreeing
to people being dishonest cheaters liars
he's deluded
why do you think men and women are
different we carry children correct you
know we nurture we're you know
compassionate emotional beings men are
very different i agree however i don't
think it's very fair for men to sit with
the opinion that it's acceptable for men
to cheat i didn't even say that but i
think if we as intelligent logical
beings as you are and as i am if we
agree that men and women are not the
same then our paradigms on how we enact
in certain regards cannot be seen as the
same so if but so if i'm with you
correct
and i then cheat that's disgusting i
can't believe you've even said that on
on youtube you see you just said on
youtube i'm sorry to the world please
don't listen to this
no no it does not no no no no please
don't say this on youtube you're going
to corrupt the youth i'm sorry for her
i'll pray for her
she seems can't be said women can't do
that women can't do that so it's a
double standard it's a double standard
but life is full of double standards if
it doesn't mean any legalism regardless
of your philosophies and everything that
you keep from not my philosophy but i'm
saying okay life is for the double
standards i understand that but in a
relationship it's a partnership yes
right you and me we're together since
when you know what i'm saying when
you're when you're trying to build a
partnership and a life with someone the
end goal is you two together agreed so
why cheat i know i understand where
you're coming from my point is that
relationships and life is full of double
standards as a whole a man's gonna pay
for everything everywhere you go right
this isn't this is dude is a man do you
agree no i do like traditional okay so
you agree so you're traditional right so
if you want to talk about traditional
let's talk about tradition every single
man since the dawn of human time had
more than one woman every single king
every single emperor every single sultan
every single conqueror since the dawn of
human time had more than one woman all
of them every single one read a history
book read the bible it's all in there
the quran all of it you won't talk about
tradition it's all there the only reason
your mind is different the only reason
you believe differently is because the
society society's come along and told
you something this is like we can change
like the world evolves things change the
world evolves yeah that's right now now
men cut their dicks off in their chicks
you believe in this [ __ ] you got the
pain you believe in any of this crap
it's all a lie i feel like lots about
choices life is about choices correct my
point is this
if i had a woman i would decide not to
cheat because i decide however i would
not see my infidelity as nearly anywhere
near even one percent as disgusting as
female infidelity because female
infidelity just involves emotion you
will not sleep with a man you don't like
i can sleep with a woman i don't like
it's completely a different thing i can
be head over heels in love with a woman
ready to die for her ready take a bullet
for her protect her give her all the
money in the world make sure she has a
beautiful family a nice big house all of
it and i'll still [ __ ] that [ __ ] watch
me a woman won't do that so don't lie to
me and pretend no you won't any woman
who will sit here and say i can do do
not care about them is fundamentally
broken her soul is broken yeah well
she's broken then but she's still doing
it well if she's broken she anywhere
near me i don't know broken [ __ ] near
me i'm definitely sure women would treat
cheat on you you think so well those are
the kind of women i will not associate
with females shouldn't even want to
cheat and the reason women can't cheat
is because there's no way to ensure
paternity of a female's cheating modern
science in and of itself just because
you can now find out who the dad is
doesn't undo 5 000 years of human
evolution in which a female had to be
loyal to one man so he knew exactly who
the father was if a man has multiple
partners you know who the mother is you
know who the father is the woman has
multiple partners nobody knows who the
dad is nobody wants to look after the
kid and a woman with a child without a
father or without a man around in the
ancient world was toast
he talks a lot of nothing
i would never ever be with a girl who
cheats on me and i would never ever you
can't you can't yes i can
yes i can yes
of course i can't no you can't like
because the thing is like this is just
an assumption i'm assuming you know do
you have a nice life
no but i'm saying you have a nice life
you live a good lifestyle women would
you see you as an opportunity
if i was a dumbass yeah yeah but this
one said your attitude is what keeps a
woman also like do you think a
high-value woman is going to sit there
and tolerate a man condescending and
talking to her and being like we're
different and we're this we're that
because we're not a woman knows how a
woman that knows her worth is not going
to tolerate that as professionals we
discussed the infidelity of females and
i said that female infidelity is more
disgusting than male infidelity and i
think that the world agrees with me
history agrees with me the bible agrees
with me the quran agrees with me every
single book you can read from history
says that females who are promiscuous
should either be stoned to death or at
least cast out from society female
promiscuity is a brand new concept this
is brand new amongst society the idea
that women can sleep with a bunch of
dudes and it doesn't matter is a brand
new idea 30 40 years old maybe even
today nobody respects it deep down when
a girl shoots a girl she doesn't like
you know the first thing she does she's
a you know why because they know deep
down they're female promiscuity is
disgusting as revolting so the whole
idea of a female wanting to sleep with
more than one man at a time is haram and
they know it inside of their souls
inside of their hearts
as yes they do as does a man whereas a
man if he sleeps with a bunch of chicks
doesn't matter who cares so would you be
with me if i'd slept with over 50 men
i'm a high-value woman right
you said it yourself how can you be high
value
if 50 men have touched with you if i've
just been single for a long time no
unacceptable why is it unacceptable
our body count is probably the number
one most easiest way to judge the value
of a female i actually think
that 90 no no no no i'm going to say
this
i think 99 of the world's problems
and no one's going to understand this
but if you can extrapolate if you can
listen to this statement and extrapolate
it out towards society at large
i think 99 of the world's problems would
be solved
if females walked through life with
their body count on their forehead
because it would prevent because it
would prevent all of the
disintegration of morals
it would prevent so many things about
the world but you know what it is like
and women would be like
to be with me as a man
i don't want to put another number on my
forehead you have to be a good man they
wouldn't stop [ __ ] these idiots and
stop being idiots and all the idiocy
would disappear all the degeneracy would
disappear families would return
virgins meeting their first man staying
with him her whole life and being proud
of it
couldn't we go back to such a beautiful
age all we have to do is start putting
numbers on girls foreheads we could fix
everything that attitude is disgusting
it's not about women's body count that
would not like minimize any problems men
like you are the problem andrew women i
myself am one of i'm sick of men that
have this really disgusting outlook on
women police in women's bodies listen if
i want to sleep with this many people i
can and i will
yeah but what you're not getting is
there's this whole hyper toxic
independent
movement of women right we are doing
things because it's kind of now it's our
choice but it's kind of like by force in
the sense of
it's like we're so liberated because
we're literally exhausted with men on
their power trip on their this so it's
like oh if you can do it we can do it
but this is also you
you men that think the way you think
have created that i understand your
point however you're wrong
uh
she thinks i'm arrogant
i'm being arrogant on purpose i must
admit annoying her is is kind of fun
i think that uh
you know what i'm being so nice
something so nice to you i say i think
instead of i know this is him being nice
the answer is i know i know
females who sleep with lots of men first
things first i don't think that women
naturally intrinsically want to do that
i think that's societal programming i
think that women no i agree this is what
i'm saying to you like there's things
that you're saying like i don't describe
certain things you're saying but going
back to my point it's like by force like
i it's to prove a point it's like this
power struggle like i personally don't
want to sit and sleep with loads of men
i don't care like
we're getting somewhere you see god
jesus i'm getting her please little by
little got two hours left give me some
time i'll fix it no but if i want to
then i'm going to sorry the best way
that's why you need something
no but genuinely but that's what you
need no you will not god will frown upon
you you can't do that and you do you
mean and me it doesn't say in the bible
i can't do that read the book i can do
whatever i want i'm a man women can't do
those things it's disgusting
i can't believe you're poisoning the
youth on youtube why is he shouting the
idea that a woman can sleep with as many
people as what she wants just because
she wants to is wrong it's absolutely
wrong every man knows it and every woman
knows it women should not do that and
the whole idea and the whole concept
that females can adopt the promiscuity
of males because males have always been
promiscuous but there's actually a lot
of men that are like good loyal men just
you know do you think so absolutely
i know
very good
men would you would you deem them high
value man oh absolutely successful
everything that i listed earlier 100
and they don't cheat right yeah
it's possible
[Laughter]
this no seriously this guy is so toxic
and the only kind of people that listen
to his kind of his advice are broke men
or heartbroken men that are insecure
i think that if a man has options over a
long enough times frame he's gonna
eventually probably explore one of them
options now i'm not saying he's gonna
love another woman i'm saying that man
who when a man's in love he only loves
one girl i agree with that i believe in
love i believe a man cares about chick i
believe men should take care of a woman
i believe you should come home to the
same place every day i believe all those
things however i think if a man truly
has options truly that both the man and
the woman understand that at some point
he's going to explore those options no
listen if i'm with you do you think i'm
going to allow you to explore other
options decide if you're with me or
you're not go go be single then cool
like what but realistically what's what
self-respecting woman is going to sit
there and tolerate
you i don't cheat i don't cheat i'm a
good man i don't choose a woman is going
to if you have all these other options
because i'll tell you what's more
powerful what's more alpha and what's
more attractive and what's more high
value is a man that can respect his
woman yeah love her not cheat on her not
disregard her not see himself above her
not see him as you know she's his slave
or anything like that see her as an
equal treat her with respect and put on
that that's more powerful a partnership
to people not i'm a man i have options
i'm gonna explore them listen if you're
a cheater you're a cheater if you're a
loyal person you're a little person
that's it
first things first men and women are not
equal we'll talk about that in a second
secondly is that if a woman sees it sees
chris brown in the club do you think
she's like wow he'll be loyal
[ __ ] no she doesn't care like a high
enough status is a man we don't even
care about loyalty women we care about
loyalty at high enough status i'm not
and i don't cheat listen i'm a man of
god i go to church i don't cheat i'm
talking about in general okay but i'm
trying to explain to you those because
maybe your perception of what a
high-value woman is is what because i'm
high-value women i make my own money i
possess all the qualities i listed
earlier right i believe i'm not going to
be with a man that's going to cheat i'm
not going to look at a man like chris
brown and be like oh my god like he's
loyal it you see you see it as face
value you know he's a cheat and maybe
he'd just be a one-night guy just like
you men do it would you sleep with him
for one night i don't think i would i
hope not because that would not make you
all one value
because it's like when you hold yourself
in high regard you don't need to do
those things so the kind of caliber of
women that go for men like that and
these opportunities don't have that much
self-worth because it's what you're
going to go with a man that's only deep
like only values you for one night so it
says a lot about the quality of a woman
right so we agree on something but i'm
saying so when you generalize about
women don't do that because there are
many high-value women who would refuse
him that will not tolerate that
completely i'm not saying that my point
is you to completely misunderstand me
i'm saying at a certain point females
aren't even interested in loyalty do you
think people do you think all the girls
with dan balzer think he's loyal i'm not
saying every girl will go with him i'm
saying there are certain girls at a
certain level of male achievement who
are not interested in but is that
attractive like for me personally that's
not attractive to sit there good and see
a man that thinks it's cool to have
loads of women around him be like oh my
god they're [ __ ] this is i have all
this money that doesn't impress me that
doesn't impress a lot of women it's
about raising the family it's about
unity
everything that you were saying
that it's not that talking about all
these celebrities xyz high enough value
when they have options they will explore
them that's what i'm saying and i'm also
saying that if a man did decide to
explore his options it would not be as
disgusting as if a female decided to
explore okay wouldn't that just be
disgusting then no it's different if a
woman does it it's different if a woman
does it everyone watching this knows
it's different if a woman cheats it's
different honestly men with these sexist
views like it's so outdated what kind of
relationship do you have with your
mother a good one a good one yeah i take
care of her and and and also that
paradigm the whole idea that if you find
a man who's good with his mom then he's
good with girls that's that's possible
no no it was just more because i find
that your faults
towards women are quite disrespectful do
you think so
why this arrogance that you've got don't
tell me what i i'd actually like to know
what i've said that so far i'm just
saying it's it's not you don't have to
say anything it's like energy speaks
volumes because you're not actually
listening to what i'm saying i'm
listening to everything you're saying i
don't think you're listening to what i'm
saying i'm saying women shouldn't sleep
with lots of men and they should fall in
love with one man and stay with that man
and if that man takes care of them and
ends up across 20 years sleeping with
one chick once you shouldn't leave him
that's all i'm saying that's all i'm
saying and the point i'm making is
completely valid and if a woman sleeps
with one man once that's unacceptable
what if a man does it it's acceptable
that's the point i'm making do you just
want women to be submissive to you i
think in a healthy relationship there's
always
a leader whether it's the man or the
woman and i think that
in the happiest relationships demands in
charge i don't think women should be
submissive to an idiot i don't think
women should be submissive to any man
they meet and i don't think women should
be submissive when they're not rewarded
right if a captain is in charge of a
ship he's responsible for the ship right
if he's responsible for the ship he has
authority over the ship okay but it's a
i'm a woman i'm not sure a relationship
okay the ship is a relationship i know
exactly what this guy's doing it's just
like talking in riddles like none of it
actually makes sense if you actually
listen to what he's saying so i think if
a man has responsibility and he takes
care of the woman and improves her life
and makes sure that every single facet
of her life whether spiritual physical
financial et cetera is taken care of
then he should have some degree of
authority i don't see why a man would
take care of a woman and have no
authority over her while accepting all
of the responsibility that's getting
played you're an independent woman maybe
you make your own money you wanna do all
those things that's fine fantastic but
if if i had a woman i would say look i
like that you do your own things i like
it you do your jobs but let's keep it
part time i want you to come with me we
gotta go here we go go there i'm
thinking around the world you're with me
i'm taking care of you et cetera and i'd
expect her to listen to me in return why
wouldn't she i'm not going to do
anything wrong or bad but if i were to
say
i don't like that dude stop talking to
him i'm her man not that dude it
shouldn't even be a competition she
should be all right cool
why wouldn't it be but then if i said i
didn't like that woman
i don't know about that this is what i'm
saying it's just a double standard and
it's just like a power struggle like
it's about balance
and this is the thing like i feel a lot
of women could give you that life and be
like you know what he can have a
girlfriend he can there's so many people
that are into that i'm not even saying
no i'm not saying there's people that
are into that correct but i'm not a
cheater i don't want to think this is
about me i'm talking about general but
do you think women want to sit here and
look stupid like i might think you know
actually i'm listening to everything
you're saying i'm agreeing and i'm
liking it but then if you've got me out
here looking stupid because you might be
in clubs with all these women around you
making me look like a idiot do you think
i'm going to tolerate that no when you
have men like
you have explained it's as if you're
trying to prove a point to the world
that you're this great man that has all
these options and you're so successful i
agree it doesn't work
if there was a man which is not me
because i'm a one-woman man but if there
was a man who decided to have multiple
girlfriends his approach certainly
wouldn't be sitting down and saying it
the way i'm saying it the point i'm
trying to make is i think that the idea
of a man having a girlfriend who he
loves
and maybe sometimes stepping out is not
nearly as offensive as the idea of a
woman having a man she loves and
sometimes stepping out
you know i watched american pie the
other week and i thought that would have
been the best time to be alive you know
like 2003. like you can still call the
people you care about if it's a real
emergency but no one's glued to their
phone no one's scrolling social media no
one's trying to take an instagram
picture everyone's just at the crappy
party enjoying the crappy party like if
you go to dubai and you look around the
bar half the people aren't having fun
they're just purely trying to get into
the stories to look like they're having
fun so it's pure like ha ha
okay so i think that a lot of people now
are doing things not because they enjoy
them because other people will think
they're having fun and it's more about
creating envy as opposed to actually
enjoying yourself
if you go on a really fun night out you
don't take your phone out so when i see
someone who went on a night out and took
20 stories dancing and laughing and
having a great time i know they're bored
yeah they're not in the moment do you
know what i mean because if you really
have a great night out you don't take
any stories and you you forget to check
your phone social media has completely
and really changed the world it's
changed the way that we function it's
changed the way that we go out it's
changed even the places we go social
media now runs the world we live in an
attention society and people will do
anything for attention because attention
is a currency and you can turn attention
into money
jake paul is not rich because he's a
boxer he's rich because he used the
attention he gets and monetized it via
boxing so in the attention economy we
now live in you have to understand that
your attention is valuable especially as
a man and women are out here today
trying to extract your attention from
you without returning anything that's
what the male female friendship is in
the old days man would give attention in
return for sex
but nowadays men just give attention and
don't get any sex back and that's what
you have to be very very careful of your
attention is extremely valuable so for
all the men out there if you're
following a woman
and you have zero chance of [ __ ] her
and she ain't replying to your dms
stop following her
like when's the last time you truly
truly lived at the moment i think i
personally live in the moment a lot no
no but that's a good thing right that's
a beautiful thing and that's a that's
actually uh an asset like my brother is
very similar to that but the problem is
if you live very very much in the moment
you're not on your phone i feel like and
i can only talk from the masculine
perspective you're not competitive
because as a man you need to be doing
things talking to people making money
moving things you're going to be on your
phone all the time really like how you
just delivered what you said but i just
find it crazy how we've just sat and
said about people need to live in the
moment and that but then like you've
sold courses trying to explain to people
how to be like that right it's just
aspire for this this this i understand i
understand what you mean but
unfortunately and it's an unfortunate
reality of the world
is that it's player versus player like
if you if you go to a video game if you
play call of duty right there's 20
people in there we're all trying to kill
each other
and the world is very very similar
financially i'm not saying we should be
out here killing each other but i'm
trying to explain that there's a certain
amount of resources and everyone's
trying to get it
and i understand your perspective but
your perspective is feminine as it
should be because you're a woman right
but the masculine imperative and the
masculine perspective is you have to
understand that life is war it's a war
for the female you want it's a com it's
a competition every chick's trying every
man's trying to get her it's a war for
the car you want it's a war for the
money you want it's a war for the status
it's a war
masculine life is war if you're a man
who doesn't view life as war you're
going to lose so as a man you have to
wake up and think okay everything i want
other men want i have to out-compete
every other man to get it so how am i
going to do that am i going to do that
by living in the moment ignoring my
phone having a fun picnic do you believe
in men's mental health you are kind of
like the problem in society in a sense
thank you fast car women lifestyle but
it is this this is the problem it's not
my problem i'm not saying it's your
problem directly but i'm saying this is
the problem yes all men probably want to
aspire for that but do you see the
pressure there is on men completely it
is much harder to be a man than be a
woman okay so what's your thoughts on
men's mental health i agree it's much
harder to be a man than be a woman which
is basically what you just said
society's expectations of men is much
higher than the societal societal
expectations of females i agree much
more is expected of us i agree it's a
harder game just like
every other video game on earth it's a
harder game but if you complete it you
get a higher score i think that being a
top tier male is the best human
experience that any human can have i
think that being a female would not
compare in any way to being a top level
man
but no no reason why there's experiences
right like women we can literally
carry lives
inside of us
i agree with you and i'm actually glad
you chose that experience because that's
the most important thing a female can do
and i agree with you and i understand
it's a beautiful thing because there's
no society and there's no world without
life i agree with you however i think
that as a man you can build an empire
there's conquest as a man and i think as
a female is not quite the same and i'm
not saying this in any kind of way that
disrespects females i don't want people
to look at this and think i'm
disrespecting females i'm not i'm saying
we have different roles we do different
things and women give life women have a
very very important role probably the
most important role in society women are
beautiful creatures that do something
separate that men cannot do i think a
top-tier male is more unique than a
beautiful woman i think that you get to
build an empire i think that you get to
be respected and feared in a way that
women never are i understand that that's
a very very unique human experience
right most men never ever get there the
reality of life for most men is
absolutely depressing i completely
understand we talk about male 1 have you
so have you suffered from mental health
[ __ ] no no absolutely not because i
understood that as a man you must build
yourself as a female you can be like but
did you not like we need to stop going
into philosophies and just stuff because
i'm actually trying to i want to
understand you okay right so you have
you or have you not experienced mental
health no zero okay so how do you cope
with stress and situations express your
emotions when you're frustrated and when
you're stressed good question
and
if i'm stressed or i'm frustrated then i
understand it's my time to perform and i
agree that society puts huge pressure on
men and it's time for men to perform as
a man you either perform or you don't
it's there's no there's no safety net
like there is for females females can
wake up and say i don't feel like it
yeah but there is for men
the men who say i can't feel like it
cannot compete with the men who do not
say that and it's player versus player
the man who goes to the gym every single
day regardless of how he feels will
always beat the man who goes to the gym
when he feels like going to the gym and
it's player versus player and let me
tell you something as much as you want
to sit here and disagree with me it's
women who decide who the winner is you
will choose the man who's in fantastic
shape you'll choose the man with all his
money right i like a dead bod personally
okay well that maybe you're you're an
exception because you're an angel but in
general we're talking in general
generalizations because exceptions do
not disprove the rule females will
choose the man who's in fantastic shape
females will choose the man who's got
his money right females will choose the
man who can fix any problem females will
choose the man when they can go to him
and say everything's can you fix this
and he says yes without panicking that's
who women want women decide who the
winner is women don't want the man when
you come to him with your problems and
he goes oh i'm too stressed today tell
me tomorrow women don't want that but
women also don't want a [ __ ] but
having your life in order doesn't make
you a [ __ ] you can have all those
things right but then there's that fine
line where your ego gets a bit too much
for example like you could be very
successful you can have good-looking
women that are attracted to you you can
just have all those qualities but then
once you possess that you then suddenly
can go past that line your ego then you
start to become an [ __ ] i agree with
you but i'm not talking about that i
think that's a separate conversation no
i'm just i'm just saying no i agree
that's what i'm saying like for me i
agree with everything you're saying but
what i'm trying to argue is the men get
successful they become even more
narcissistic and they just are not nice
people to be around you're very very
smart thank you you are but you're doing
what most females do and you're
conflating issues so when you conflate
what you do is you mix two issues
together to try and prove your point no
i'm actually i've just been asking you
personal questions and every time you
give me a philosophy no it's not
philosophy no but i'm saying in general
when i'm asking you i'm trying to get to
know you on a level how does a woman
like me get to know a gentleman like you
here at this beautiful nice civil dinner
we're having here with no with no
animosity at all
you asked me about men's mental health
my answer was explaining that as a man
you don't have the luxury oops i don't
feel like it you can do it you can't but
something i'm sorry i know i keep
cutting you but i'm just like because
this is the part that gets really
frustrating for me like men with this
mindset that you have like i get it okay
great you are alpha you've achieved
no but i'm saying like you possess all
these it's great but you are the problem
you're creating this pressure
in society
but you men can actually successful men
can actually be like okay i don't
actually feel like it today like they
actually can i
rest at that i unders
my point is that it's player versus
player and if you're a man who's going
to constantly give in to mental health
problems or mental health trouble you're
not going to be able to compete with the
men who don't okay but can we validate
men that have completely if you have
mental
health we can't go play a pledges
validate men that have mental health
issues absolutely okay men who have
mental health issues i hope them i wish
them the best in the world but when they
come to me and say and i get this all
the time andrew i have this problem i'm
depressed and i can't go to the gym i
say no i disagree you're depressed
because you don't go to the gym if you
go to the gym you might start to feel
better right i'm saying you can't sit as
a man and afford the luxury of saying i
have a mental health issue today i'm sad
today i'm stressed today i'm emotional
today i can't work because
you will lose against the men who don't
do that and male the male world is more
competitive than you could possibly
imagine and it's the women who pick the
winners so i find it i find it very
interesting that a woman sits here to me
and says no men are allowed to sit
around and do [ __ ] all and feel sad and
those are the men they ignore when they
dm no no no no
no they ignore them all no actually can
i just can i just try them in here so
for example everything you've said
you've possessed you've proved your
point right but as a high value woman if
i respect and love my partner i'm not
putting that pressure i would say babe
you know what you can have a little rest
like there are women that actually
enable men to feel process that emotion
i agree but yeah so we'll still go back
to tomorrow okay
let's go back to work work work but
there are good women out there that
don't put that pressure i feel like your
reality on women is warped because of a
certain caliber of women yes it is i
agree you're right but you need to
you're missing a very vital point of
that story you're right but the as a
high value woman before you say to that
man you can have a day off and you're
allowed to be sad today you will only
even get with him
we change that you will only even
acknowledge he exists if he's ignored
how he feels 99 of the time before that
because if he was sad most of the time
before that he never would have got to a
place where he could attract a woman
like you the man who works in starbucks
who's sad all the time you won't reply
to him
neither will any other female so for
women to come along and pretend they
give a [ __ ] about the fact that most men
are basic most men are basically
invisible there is not a female on the
planet who's invisible today you can be
a four overweight fat you'll still go to
the club and get attention 99 of the men
go to the club and nobody even [ __ ]
talks to them if they try and talk to a
girl they get blanked and ignored and
told
most men are absolutely not really
invisible this is the truth about
masculinity right it's very easy for
women to sit here and complain about the
top two percent of men because i melt
death with this guy's arrogant blah blah
blah blah most men don't even [ __ ]
exist they send 10 000 dm's and never
even get read let alone replied to so if
you just sit here and say i'll get a g a
big g a boss a millionaire and let him
have a day off very nice of you i'm sure
you would but if you got if a guy who
wanted to have days off all the time he
never would have gotten important enough
in the first place to attract a woman
like you and that is the reality as a
man it's player versus player it's
ultimately competitive and as a man you
have to out-compete the other men who
are prepared to get up and do it anyway
that's how it works there's no such
thing as saying i'm sad i need two weeks
off not as a man if you want to be
important maybe it's a chick you'd
always put more foundation on be hot
again great not as a man if you want to
be important as a man you have [ __ ] to
do you have duties this is how it exists
how it's always been
why are you wearing glasses sunglasses
yeah we're inside we are inside very
perspicacious of you
i have bad eyes your bad eyes i have bad
eyes because
after so many fights in the ring i had a
retina detachment and there's a lot of
bright lights here and it makes my eyes
very uncomfortable i don't want to
squint
on camera so i'm wearing sunglasses so
if you want to continue to make fun of
my medical condition why would i make
fun of it you just tried it i know you
just tried no that's fine no no it's
fine it was it was a genuine question
yeah yeah yeah yeah i try to make money
it's fine versus
mental health but if you've got a retina
detachment it's fine no no hahaha
actually now actually i was asking you
because eye contact is important to
gauge conversation is it i want to do it
like how we're enjoying yeah
let me see give it a few minutes it's
you know etiquette isn't it it is you're
right it's polite you're right it's
polite perfect do we cheers the glasses
off
kids to detach retinas
choose
are you happy
i think that money buys freedom and
freedom buys happiness
i think that the rich people of the
world the number one most intelligent
thing they did was convince poor people
that money isn't happiness and i think
they did that to prevent revolts i'm not
saying money is the only thing that can
make someone happy i'm not saying money
alone will make you happy
but money is certainly a factor to to
happiness yeah it's kind of yeah you
agree right it's like water right walter
won't make you happy but if you have no
water after a week you need water it's
all you think about right it's the same
deal you can't go without it so the rich
people always say money doesn't buy
happiness but do they ever give their
money away yeah exactly you know what
i'm saying so give your money away i
have a charity which i own which takes
care of street dogs in romania
so i rescue dogs that's really lovely
thank you see we're getting along there
that's really nice see it's much better
do charity work glasses are off
actually connecting with a real human
i'm a real human you look really nice
and you smell nice thank you i'm uh yeah
dressed up for you of course yeah it's
nice it's nice to see someone make the
effort you know where i'm from
in eastern europe i always wear a suit
because we can carry weapons over there
here in london it's a little bit
different we have to take security with
us but where i'm from you have to jack
it because you have to strap it's
different different game so do you walk
around with a weapon
no
wait wait wait
yes enemies are watching listen i'm
ready let's leave it at that but i'm
very security conscious now and i think
that there's a difference between
fighting and violence and even though
i'm a professional fighter if you want
to be a professional violence you need a
weapon at some level okay that's my
answer interesting
just imagine in these scenarios we are
together okay what would you do if i
wanted to start and only fans i don't
think there's anything intrinsically
wrong with women doing only fans
as long as i had influence and control
over it what do you mean doing a video
photographer to get the angles no no no
no not doing any real work but just like
taking all the money
if my chick said i want to do only fans
i'm like all right then cool go do it
how much you made 10 grand or give me
eight all right cool why would what
woman is going to give you eight grand
because she's my you're my woman you're
doing only fans you're selling my
product the [ __ ] you're products yes
next question
no
product like do you own me no no sorry
like your ego is bitter you don't own me
i'm not a product i'm not an object
okay mr tate
understanding
i don't know if you're being serious i'm
totally serious how would i let my chick
the only thing to keep all the money
that's disrespectful what woman is ever
going to give you that then she better
know your only fans duh
oh my god that upset her didn't it upset
her to say that you're mine and if
you're mine and men want to pay for it
then the money is mine but that's the
basic dynamic of a relationship you're
mine so if you want to sell what is mine
that's fine but i need to get paid what
would you do if i couldn't cook
that's fine we are every day no problem
i i haven't had a home-cooked meal on
yours anyway no way no i eat out nearly
every day three times a day oh my god
always traveling always moving even when
i'm home is saying restaurants so do you
ever want to just settle down i feel
like your life just seems like it's just
really fast-paced do you not want just a
nice woman if she cooks for me that'd be
beautiful but it's not it's not a deal
breaker okay like that what if i earned
more money than you impossible
never lie no no no impossible really
literally impossible is it impossible
literally impossible numbers don't go
that high next question
it's impossible for her to earn more
money than me simply because of her
ethos towards life
her ethos towards life is about moments
and memories my ethos towards life is
about conquest and those are very very
different things i completely understand
that she enjoys things which are not
congruent with trying to conquer earth
she wants time off she wants holidays
she wants to enjoy time with friends she
wants to do a bunch of things that don't
make money i want to make money it's
impossible she could ever earn more than
me because we have completely different
life philosophies
what would you do if i didn't like your
lifestyle what what aspect of my
lifestyle maybe it was too flashy for me
flying around too much maybe i just want
you to just slow down it's a bit too
fast place i understand and i and i
would respect the point of view so what
are you doing i don't think i'd listen
my lifestyle got me to where i am and i
i'm a sovereign individual who lives in
the way he believes true i would listen
and i would understand it and i'll do my
best to accommodate but i don't think i
would change
if you were to say look you can't do
this anymore i'd say oh i'm going to do
anyway sorry i'll try to make you feel
better about it but it's going to happen
what if your family didn't like me
that's not a big deal not a big deal
yeah
the only the only person i'm super close
with is my brother okay and my brother
wouldn't dislike you unless he had a
reason like a genuine reason and if he
disliked you i'd dislike you so then the
game over anyway not because he dislikes
you but because we have the same
standards of life there's no way he
could dislike you without me disliking
says literally two of you that have
these mad views my views are not mad
what have i said so far what have i said
so far women shouldn't be hoes man
should have some authority because he
should take care of his chick chicks
shouldn't
talk to a bunch of dudes why are you
shouting it's important for the mic no
it's not because
that's it that's all i've said and
you're and you're saying i got crazy
views but then they said like the
loudest person in the room is the
weakest oh my week now no but i'm just
saying don't people say that
i'm not doing an arm myself come on i
want to see it come on no you look
strong look i'm a nice feminine lady
that doesn't like to do these activities
okay or if i wanted to invite other
people into our sex life obviously i'm
gonna ask if it's boys or girls but even
then even those girls would be weird i
think it'd be a bit strange if i had a
girlfriend she said i really want you to
[ __ ] this chick i'd be like
this is not the normal feminine mindset
you must not like me but it just seemed
odd to me something would be up i'm
really surprised by that answer i don't
know why i feel like you'd be the type
of person that would want loads of
threesomes and stuff and feel like yes
this lifestyle i'm the man sexton in and
of itself is boring any man who sits and
says that sex is great or sex is fun
just clearly hasn't had enough sex
because sex is boring sex is a chore sex
is like food you don't really care
unless you're really hungry and then you
eat and you don't care again and it's
one of the yeah it's one of those things
you go you do every once in a while
because it's an urge but it's not a real
big deal like
every every person needs food and every
person likes food have you ever been in
love completely but somewhere having sex
and making love yeah different no no if
you're in love you might want sex more
often you might be hungry more often my
point is that if you're someone who goes
through life and only only only talks
about and cares about food it's a bit
weird same thing with sex sex is
something that happens and this happens
between people who love each other and
it's a great thing but it's not the be
all and end all of life it's really not
that great i don't think sex is the i
don't think sex is the most stimulating
interesting thing in the world doesn't
matter who the girl is this might be
lover or not i don't think it's the
greatest best thing in the world any
dude who's that was like wow wow two
pairs of tits
just hasn't [ __ ] very much who gives a
[ __ ] do you think you've overachieved so
much already this is why you're kind of
latin jaded
no i i i just think that men who are
super super interested in
sex or sexual fantasies of these things
are men who are semi-deprived you have
an abundance of food if you have a
fridge full of food all the time you
don't eat all the time sometimes you
just don't want to it's always there
right but if you're starving as soon as
food appears you're all over it it's the
same with sex any dude was like wow
threesome okay i need i need is a guy
who's deprived a guy who has as much as
he wants all the time ain't going to be
really that interested in it so you're
comparing women to food okay correct
what would you do if i was going on
girls holidays every other month
i'd have to shut that down i think it's
disrespectful do you go on a lot of
holidays i can do whatever i want we're
not actually going to go there with this
[ __ ]
double standard [ __ ] this man has so
many double standards like it actually
doesn't make sense i'm i think he
honestly believes like his own rubbish
it's not double standards it is there's
different standards but i'm saying but
if you are out every month doing this
doing that great i'm going to do the
same to keep myself entertained and
occupied this is what you think i'm
going to wait at home for you
and just wait there look like an idiot
then probably see you upload on
instagram here's this livestream
as you should there's there's no way i
would allow
my you there's no way i would allow you
to go on all these girls holidays that's
very disrespectful i'm a territorial man
that does not mean jealous or insecure
it means i care about you anything i
care about i want to protect and love it
doesn't matter how doesn't matter how
much you love me back doesn't matter it
doesn't matter if no man on earth could
talk you into bed it's not about that
it's about the disrespect it's okay for
you to disrespect me it's not
disrespectful for me to go on holidays
or go work with my boys my holidays are
work trips no no that's impossible
you're not running the world like i am
this [ __ ] how do you know i know
these things don't lie to me this is
something that you wouldn't don't lie to
me
it's absolutely disrespectful for a
woman to be with a man and then want to
run around with her girls and pretend
she's still single she shouldn't even
want to the fact she even asked to go in
and of itself is disrespectful i
shouldn't have to tell her not to do
that listen i will call all of my girls
and go on a girl's holiday just to piss
you off mate what if i went on a holiday
twice a year with the girls you wouldn't
want to i definitely no you wouldn't
you're with me you don't want to you we
go on holidays together we go places
together when i have to go places with
just a boys you stay home you do not go
on girls holidays it's disrespectful i
find it disrespectful it's like a slap
in the face how is it because why would
you want to do that if you're with a man
you love you wouldn't want to do that i
shouldn't even have to tell you not to
do that you're going to have me just at
home looking stupid whilst you're doing
that right
but i'm saying if you're just going to
go up and do that you're obsessed with
people thinking you look stupid
no people will look at you and go wow
she is a loyal
wife but that's for you
but this is for your it's not about
obeying yeah it is she loves her man she
doesn't need to go on one of these girls
holidays do i be throwing around being a
hoe she's over all that [ __ ]
it could just be like women just go on
holiday to have fun and men will try and
sleep with you so
does that mean the women are correct if
this is what i'm saying i'll agree with
this no no agreed let me agree with you
it's not worth reality because we agree
we agree no we're not moving on to the
next question no we agree we agree
you're right they're gonna try and
you're not gonna let them i agree if i
walk out to the car park it doesn't
matter how good the locks are on my car
if someone's trying to break into my car
am i gonna let them keep trying no no
it's disrespectful it's mine and no one
comes near it because it's mine no one's
gonna try and steal it for me too i'll
put it in a place where people are going
to try and steal it is nothing less than
irresponsible my females taken care of
and has a fantastic life she does not
need to go on holidays to [ __ ] make
an awesome be a hoe on some random table
some random table because her friend met
some dude on [ __ ] tinder no stay home
stay home they bet it's not but this is
like i feel like you're enabling this
whole like controlling a municipality
it's not controlling it
to say to safety but the way you just
said it
yeah with that kind of like tenacity
yeah like for me it's just yeah it's not
controlling to say to your woman okay if
you want a holiday
yeah the way i said it angered you
because everything i say is deliberately
designed to anger you it's you have this
power and control issue and i feel like
it's just mad it's like
today with your like girls going on
holiday with their friends is not an
unreasonable thing it's a normal thing
women should be able to do it in some
relationships okay but in my
relationship in this one yeah
what would you do we just met and we've
had a one-night stand and i've got
pregnant
the baby's innocent right i'd look after
the child it depends on a lot of
scenarios afterwards i'd make sure the
child's financially taken care of if you
were prepared to be a loyal woman i'd
make sure you were taken care of if
you're gonna start sleeping with other
dudes whatever then it's your problem
babies your problems are your problem
but if you're gonna be loyal to me still
then i'd take care of you but if you're
gonna start saying oh no i've got a new
man now cool you can pay the bills it's
not my problem no when you have a child
that's your responsibility no but if you
want to stick with other dudes then it's
his problem
it's an accident right so you shouldn't
be punished in life and the child's
absolutely not really innocent i would
take care of you completely and i take
care of the child completely and i'd
always want to see the child but if you
were to say now after let's say a year
or two years whatever i have a new man
now blah blah blah blah like all right
cool kids with me twice two days a week
whatever it is i'll make sure the kids
looked after but i'm not financing you
in another man's lifestyle i'm not just
sending money to your bank at random and
just making sure that you and this dude
whoever he is are going on holiday and
whatever whatever i'll take care of the
child while while he or she is with me
and i'll always see the child but if you
have a new man you have a new man you
ain't my problem anymore you gotta pay
your own rent no because i'm in my
problem you still need to cover some
sort of responsibility there it's not
possible you should pay my whole rent
i'm just saying okay so i'm sorry yeah
but some sort is not reasonable i agree
with what you're saying they're gonna
come along and say oh you're rich give
me 10 gs a month and you're [ __ ] some
next dude but with that scenario how do
you know women aren't going to try and
trap you i'm not a form you're not a
phone no
good question all right
yeah i do
you don't do you like receiving it
absolutely not another one
don't my dear listen it's been a long
it's been a long it's been a long
evening and it's been very enjoyable
let's not start talking about how men
and women are different again you know
you're you're yes i'm no it's fine we're
offices okay that's how it should be
women are supposed to do certain things
that men can't do women are very
talented beautiful creatures you can
give life we can't do that it's fine you
can give head we can't do that this is
not for the g's i'm not i don't know
who's out here doing this but ain't me
like i'm sure there's plenty of men out
there who will do it you don't want to
please your woman though there's plenty
of ways to please a woman without doing
that that's a big factor that's a good
one
maybe for you
i think that it's possible to please a
woman without it yeah it can be okay so
i i don't i don't think it's something
that is conducive to a healthy
relationship it's not something i'm very
interested in personally yeah maybe i'm
crazy yeah that's fine i go crazy
yes
no you wouldn't hello why why the [ __ ]
would i
maintain like a good relationship what
what is this these lies
how does it lie it could be like a good
woman let's talk about masculine and
feminine friendship i understand why
you'd be friends with an eggs
because you can gain things
right you're friends with that man he
might i don't know occasionally buy you
some dinner or he might pick you up or
he might help you he's my friend yeah
because he's your friend correct
yeah those things just a friend yeah
right just yeah it's just a friend he'll
do some things for you as a woman what
friend what things will you do for him
i'm here i'm a really good friend
actually
chat [ __ ] on [ __ ] whatsapp anything
else no i saw them checking on them like
the things that i feel like men need
like we do as women men will do real
things for you a female friend won't do
[ __ ] for you besides trying to get
attention out of you that's it it's a
waste of time to have female friends as
a man complete waste of time they don't
give you anything being friends with an
ex i completely understand why she would
do it the man's going to get horny the
man's going to want to message her now
and again the man is going to want a
banger now and again the man might do
favors for her xyz but she ain't going
to do nothing for him so any man who is
friends with a woman is giving his
attention without retrieving and
receiving what he wants from a female
which is sex so it's a mistake it's a
mistake to make if you give something
away for free it has no value my
attention has value i don't give my
attention to people who don't give me
what i want in return so waste of time
what you're going to give me advice you
think any advice from some ex
your advice you can do nothing but sit
there and go hey babe and send me the
selfie trying to get attention again i
see there's a liability i see there's
something for me to pay money for for
someone to pick up someone to defend if
we randomly get an attack on the street
someone to give a [ __ ] about without any
exchange and what would you what did she
give me exchange um advice advice the
[ __ ] what dude is getting advice from
chicks what dude is getting advice from
girls any man who sits there and goes my
life ain't going right let me text some
chick he's a dumbass he's a dumbass you
should because you should go to your
boys your team no because boys do this
weird toxic alpha i'm toxic alpha it's
really isn't like it is okay if a man
has a serious issue in his life
he can't go to a woman if a man goes to
a woman with his issue it's not a
serious issue i feel sad my ex left me
some dumb [ __ ] but women can give
they're trying to kill me i need a gun
now you don't text some chick in your
phone you text your boys because only
your men who can help you i'm in ukraine
the russians have invaded i need a way
out who's got a car
oh [ __ ] cheyenne's coming doo doo doo
pergo 206 get [ __ ] don't lie to me
though women can't help you women cannot
as a man on the edge life is extreme my
dear life is extreme yes life is extreme
that was no that was yes don't lie to me
all right okay
it's not about just advice my point is
that when a man and women are a woman
are friends i think the woman extracts a
lot from the friendship and she gains a
lot of things and i don't think the man
gains things to an equal value but can i
just explain there's actually a lot of
women that don't want anything from men
what do you why are you why are you his
friend then because sometimes there's
men that possess amazing qualities and
you just want to make them greater
that's what women do we add value to
anything we do but maybe just the women
that you're surrounded by no probably
give you that warped perception because
maybe they're just [ __ ] women wrong but
the women that i know
are good women that add value to
everyone's life
women women add value completely i agree
my point is that if you're a man whose
life is in order and many men who many
men don't have a life in order right if
you're a man and your life's not in
order then maybe you can get advice from
a chick right because there's these guys
there's guys like this there's the guys
who need their girlfriend or their chick
to tell them to stop playing video games
or they need their chick to say maybe
you should go to the gym did a like a
jackass right they need mothers but if
you're a g and your life's in order
right
yeah if if you are a g and your life is
an order i'm not saying i am if your
life's in order everything's going well
you're making your money you're in good
shape you've got a good network
everything's on track you did it all
before you met some chick it's all on
track the train is on the track it's
heading towards success you don't need
female advice right most of the time
when a man and a woman are friends the
female is extracting attention from the
friendship which i don't blame her for
but females love attention i don't like
why wouldn't they right they're
extracting attention from the friendship
they might get picked up they might get
rides they might get
bought dinner
and on top of that the man still has
certain masculine responsibilities right
if someone comes up and snatches her
purse he has to run after the dude risk
his life now risk getting stabbed for
some chick who doesn't suck dick blah
blah whereas what does the man get from
the woman advice is that it a woman
can't a woman can't give the man
anything outside of a romantic
relationship inside of a romantic
relationship she can give him
she can give him love she can give him
care she can give him protective spirits
she can add peace to his life
yeah that's what we can add as a room as
a romantic partner women can just do
that as a friend no they can't
that is a lie you lied to me a woman who
is not romantic with the man cannot add
genuine peace to that right
[ __ ] lie
who are you lying to okay but this is
what i'm saying but you just think women
are only good for like
just if they're there sexually it's not
about being their sexuality it's because
they've just like a woman a woman's job
is to spiritually protect her man i mean
you can do it with a friend you can also
do that listen i pray for all of my
friends your perception of women is
messed up because maybe it's just the
certain women that you know stop stop
trying to pretend i know better no but
i'm saying but that's clearly what it is
that's clearly no it's not because
there's plenty of other good women and
this is why for me it's exhausting
explaining this to you because there's
so many good women i can't
obtain anything i'm interested in from a
friendship with a female okay it's no
hard feelings to girls i don't have any
female friends not one so it's just more
because men would want to [ __ ] their
friends men do want to [ __ ] their
friends that's a separate okay so that's
why no no no okay that's what it is no
that's a separate argument that's a
completely separate argument that we can
go into if you want every single man
wants to [ __ ] his female friend because
if if all these girls go he's just my
friend yeah put on 20 stones see if he
wants to talk to you [ __ ] no oh yeah
protect your spirit when you're fat oh
you can't do it anymore you lost your
spiritual powers now you're ugly isn't
that funny how that work out it's
[ __ ] man the man's trying to get
laid and the chicks enjoying attention
and i'm telling you that as a man you
obtain nothing from a female friendship
you obtain nothing but responsibility
without authority you're gonna sit there
and say i'm her friend i'm gonna take
care of her i'm gonna hang out with her
i'm gonna take her to cinema buy her
ticket and she's gonna go home with some
other dude stupid i'm not saying i won't
be polite to be hi nice to meet you good
to see you bye i'm never gonna be like
hey let's go for dinner we're just
friends why but friend dates is a thing
this is something
this is my brain no but this is what i'm
saying because it needs to be normalized
because if you don't have any female
friends you're just basing all your
philosophies on just women that you
don't even talk to men who pretend to be
friends with girls are just trying to
get laid because there's nothing else to
do with a friendship with a girl but
trying to trying to get laid it's just
some beta male [ __ ] trying to
pretend the grand lady okay
if they were g they'd just try she'd say
no and then move on with their life
yes okay i've got a long list of good
male friends so we'll just agree to
disagree on this put on put on 10 stone
and text them good luck
andrew what's the um war room the war
room is an organization i run
for individuals who are trying to escape
the matrix
like so can women join it women love the
matrix so what's your matrix no they're
matrix explain that i don't understand
have you seen the movie yeah so we're
living inside of a simulation right
we're all slaves on some level
and i have an organization which helps
people achieve the independence from the
systems which are designed to constrain
us so i can join it no women love
control women love control and women
love systemization so do you i love
control what
what aspects of my life do i enjoy
having control well the way i've been
analyzing this date okay analyze it yeah
i'm interested
i'm just saying it's a very power
dynamic control thing i like having
sovereignty i like having control of my
own life i don't like you know having
control over me and that's what the
matrix does whereas females i don't
think have that same mindset towards the
world i don't think women wake up and
realize that they live inside of a large
penal colony and need to find a way to
escape i don't think they do that yeah
we do do you yeah
what enslaves humanity there's a lot of
people that
are very conscious to life in situations
and stuff so i feel like it's very
small-minded for you to just think that
women can't join your matrix well it's
not small-minded because it's mine so
firstly i'm allowed to do whatever i
want and secondly i think that
my organization runs best without female
participants and it's not saying that
the female in and of herself will be a
bad person or an unworthy participant i
just think the organization is better if
it's purely male 1 for the same reason
you don't have women on the front line
like when it's all men you focus on the
task when there's a chick around there's
some showing off there's some trying to
impress the chick it just dilutes the
efficiency but i feel like you would
attract entitled women maybe to a degree
but i i also think that like everything
in life there's balance i would
completely understand a woman who said i
won't date broke men but a woman who
were to sit here and say i want x money
that's hard to get [ __ ] so it's a
balance right i understand why a woman
wouldn't want to date a man with no
money but i also would never allow a
girl to treat me like a sugar daddy what
is your type physically
there's all types of beautiful women
beautiful
beautiful
beautiful beautiful blonde is beautiful
brunette is beautiful there's hot
brunettes there's hot blondes i don't
have a type to say that i only
like one particular type of woman a
small-minded i don't think any man
thinks that way anyway maybe we have a
preference but i don't believe in a
particular type
do you believe you're in [ __ ]
i don't think anything i've said to you
so far is [ __ ] maybe the shoe thing
that's about it the rest of it's
completely true some of your views are
very extreme a bit misogynistic
and a little bit of a ego so if you had
a boyfriend would you have male friends
i would
but it's just you've just got to know
how to have boundaries with friends i'm
not going to be calling that friend past
eight o'clock if you're a man said i'm
uncomfortable you're having male friends
and you love me and we're together
forever and we're about to have a child
we're about to get married whatever stop
talking to them all would you stop no
i believe in compromise but not that
because now it's a control issue any day
as long as i make you feel like you're
my man you're miking and everything else
like that that's not on me if you're
insecure that i have male friends do you
think that's you do you think that's
interesting yes it is it's a you problem
i don't think that's insecurity it's not
to kill him territorial maybe but not in
security
andrew how do you think you've done on
the day i think that i've pissed you off
at least four times
at least yeah and i think that i could
have said everything in a far nicer way
in terms of purely attracting you i
don't think i've done that well but it's
been an interesting conversation and i
think that us both having an interesting
conversation and you've made me think a
few times i hope i've said things that
made you think a few times and i think
that's more important than just purely
the attraction so i've enjoyed myself
yeah me too good
that was hard work
we actually agree on everything i was
trying my best to say things in a way
that she couldn't allow herself to agree
with them but we actually agree on
everything i think she's smart enough to
want a man who's in charge of his life
and by extension would be in charge of
the relationship and by extension would
be in charge of her but if you say it in
that way it upsets her i don't know my
mind's a bit
like he was just draining exhausted like
men like that that actually think like
that and actually believe what they're
saying like it's mentally exhausting uh
there was a point when i wanted to say
sniper out now on all digital platforms
i didn't say that yet
i wanted to bring that one out and i
didn't but uh besides that we did good
that's the only answer i missed
no
i would not see andrew again do i look
like i'm going to see him again
no yeah exactly
i'm a busy man
i'm a busy man actually no i will do you
know what i will see again so i'm going
to prove my point that men need women as
friends how about that
i said some things she agrees with and
some things that deep down she knows are
true but i send them in a way which were
deliberately abrasive and offended her
so i think she's gonna give me a six and
a half or seven right so this guy he's
egotistical he has a delusional mindset
on women
and he thinks he's a bit too nice
however
i feel like he did have good
conversation he is a man that knows what
he wants he get obviously gets what he
wants so you can't knock it and he
looked nice so i'm gonna give him a six
[Music]
you